all right Jessica Jessica where are you
from originally where'd you grow up um I
grew up in the Fontana and Ontario
area and tell me about your family
growing up as a
kid um I would say it was very I have a
very chaotic
family so um what was going on oh man a
lot I wouldn't know where to where to
begin
but um the problem was your mom or your
dad or both um I don't know uh my real
dad personally I've talked to him on the
phone a couple of times but um I didn't
I don't have a relationship with him I
was raised by my mom and she
uh I feel like the only way I can
describe her is
very she's got she got a lot of mental
problems so
youn yeah multiple personality disorder
oh really yeah so she's
just it's always been which I think now
is called did yeah so something
something like that yeah so so she would
change her behavior oh yeah it was very
one day from the next kind of situation
so she just give me an example of how
she'd behave um I think the
biggest uh the thing that stands out in
my head would be her drinking majority
um she used to call her personality when
she would drink she would call it rage
and I think I got to know that person a
little bit more you know um I was very
loyal to my mom I was very I always no
matter what she did you know um you
still loved her oh yeah definitely
definitely till this day she was um very
suicidal when I say suicidal people
think like you know it's so much
attempts but I never got I never
understood until I got older exactly
what you know the things she would you
know she would do to herself I
personally know now that I'm older it
was a lot of times it was for attemp you
know attention a lot of um attempts were
man they were she almost did it you know
and when I was younger I think
um I think it was worse for me when I
was younger because I was so innocent at
that time like she would like shred her
wrists up you know in these open wounds
and you know me being at that age I was
always like oh gosh like here let me put
some Band-Aids on it you know so she
would knock out drunk and she's sitting
there bleeding everywhere and I would
have to you
know try and catch her up is in my mind
the best that I could you know
especially being at that age so you know
there was attempts when um since I was
young and I can remember to you know now
you know and in between that there was
you know taking care of us you know
I I can't remember a time
where you know she
actually was a top-of-the-line mom you
know so it's it's this I assume is your
entire
childhood yeah yeah there was maybe like
I want to say three years like broken up
that she would be like good you know she
would like she us to get up she would
like run in the morning she would like
you know she would really she' really
motivate me you know and then there was
times where I just was like I don't know
how I'm like why am I even why did you
even have me why did you even have us
you know so it was real it was real up
and down you know with me especially in
the beginning um
you know one point I was I was molested
and she was in this relationship for
like 18 19 years you know so I was
molested the first four years and by her
partner yeah yeah and you know my mom
has been through the whole drug thing
you know meth and you only God knows
what but she actually
um in the beginning he used to tell me
that he would kill her and my that was
my mom that was my my that's my
everything you know watching her get you
know beat awful and then you know I
would do anything to protect her I
always told myself when I was older I
was always like you know I'll I can't
wait till I get older so I can you know
so I can do some damage for you but
after a while and some certain
situations that took place I started
realizing that
she that she knew you know she knew it
was happening there was a point in time
where she had you know told me and I can
remember so clearly that day she just
was like you know you need to stop
encouraging it you're encouraging it you
know and I always lived with like this I
call it like my it's like a pit in your
stomach it's like an uncomfortable pit
it's like nausea anxiety everything
mixed together in the center of your
stomach and it's like you think about
that like gosh like is today going to be
this is she going to flip out is she
going to hurt herself she going to hurt
someone else you know like and every
time she would leave it was always like
oh man like I knew it was going to
happen you know and I got no actually I
have two other siblings I have an older
sister and I have a little brother how
did they cope with this um how are they
doing now basically is my question my uh
my older sister was actually raised by
my um by my grandparents you know my mom
kind of just you know I don't want to
say that they um I don't even want to
give her that credit that they took her
away you know like she she was okay with
it you know she didn't have like the
best relationship with my older sister
you know I feel like she always gave my
older sister the shoulder I don't think
my mom wanted girls I think she she
wanted boys you know my sister was first
born um she would she had like a blue
baby shower and I seen pictures of my
sister and like boy clothes you know she
wanted she wanted a boy you know that's
how she she's always been here come two
girls later you know and um my little
brother is is the sweetest kid ever you
know and I think he was more on the
spoiled side because he was he was
finally the boy you know that she wanted
that everybody wanted you know so um and
and that doesn't take away anything that
you know she has she's done to him too
you know like like I said it wasn't just
her she didn't realize it was everything
she did everything she said the way she
acted it impacted everybody you know and
a lot of what she did till this day um
has affected me impacted me you know
recent events that took place I
specifically say August 27th this is
this is where I decided to completely
just turn my life around and be sober
because I feel like that was the worst
she probably has ever put me my brother
and my sister through what did she do
um so my mom is on the streets right now
you know and after I think uh I'm going
to say 3 years ago I had to I had to
turn my back with helping her you know I
had to you know Let it go you know I I
have to watch from I have to watch out
for my kids you know and in my head I'm
like you know I have my own problems you
know I got my own like you know my own
things like my sobriety you know has
taken a lot of time away from my oldest
my daughter you know and um I always
told myself when I was younger I was
like you know I want to be like her you
know but you catch yourself sometimes
you don't want to be like somebody but
you I don't think some people can
realize you know you don't have to
necessarily do exactly what they do to
be like that person you can find
yourself self-destructing in different
kinds of ways me particularly is my
drinking I feel like the only time I can
be directly like my mother and just like
my mother is when I'm drinking
and that's why I and it took a long time
for me to finally realize that and um so
let me go back um she's on the streets
right now um I had given up on her
because she just you know she got
involved with this man that just
was um I mean Not only was he a
dangerous man you know he had you know
threatened you know my kids at one point
you know so I told her and she just kept
going back to that man you know that's
how my mom is that's what I think her
struggle is she can't be alone and she
always picks the worst kind of men the
men that beat her the men that use her
you know like and she's always been that
way and
um she had said that she called me one
day she asked me for money and I was
just like you know what I'm not I'm not
going to do it and my mom's the kind
like if you don't you don't give her
what she wants she's like all right I'm
you know she'll give me a goodbye
message you know I'll see you you know
um I love you take care of your brother
like it's oh it's consistent you know
but there's not a day where I don't get
anxiety thinking like gosh is this going
to be the day like it's so I live with
that every single day you know and
um
so August 27th I was at my house I was
having some wine you know and and you
know believe me we get calls all the
time you know she'll she'll post on her
own Facebook saying like oh you know
rest in peace you know and it's herself
she's putting herself on there you know
and it's like gosh like sometimes but
you got to start looking into it like
you know I get like this you know what
if I'm I'm just sitting here like it's
not real you know and
um so August 27th we um I was like I
said I was having some wine and um I get
a phone call from my brother my little
brother and he's like you know I'm
panicking and I was like what's the
matter and he was like you know there um
I seen the post on on Facebook they
saying that you know mom died 3 days ago
and I didn't think anything of it you
know forgive me for saying that but I
hear it all the time it's it's
consistent you know and it's it's the
lies and the stories are just like
astronomical so I just don't I don't
even you know not necessarily don't
believe it I just don't feed into it so
quickly I'm not so quick to just you
know toss everything in the air and go
and look for her so I um I told my
brother I was like look you need to calm
down you know my brother takes it very
differently you know he's at the point
in his life where I was you know 15
years ago where she can still she can
still hurt him with the smallest little
text message you know and that's my my
brother is like my my brother and my
sister are like to
me they're like I'm like the protector
you know I love them and I make sure I
protect my brother you know so makes be
really angry with her and so I told him
you know just calm down everything's
going to be all right and I was like
she's probably he's like no I'm hearing
it from like you know other people that
are on the streets with her are saying
that they found you know her body by the
train tracks and so I started getting a
little bit nervous and me in my alcohol
ways I started to I started just
pounding more I was just like I don't
want to hear it I don't want to think
about it this is not the kind of day
that I'm going to have you know I
um
and I called my Uncle to be like okay
you know this is what I'm hearing and he
was like you know what a medical
examiner would call us um you know
somebody will get a hold of us a police
will come to the door so I was trying to
calm my brother down you know as I'm
trying to calm myself down like no just
just relax so this is I'm going to say
like 4 hours went by you know um and
still it was the same thing you know
we're hearing this we're hearing that
and you know I had my aunt uh my uncle
calling you know around just to see
maybe did they find kind of body is
something you know and she ended up
talking to or he my brother sorry my
brother ended up talking to um that
homeless person that you know was giving
him the information he was like no I
heard that um the man that she was being
with that dangerous man you know he
killed
her and so my brother started getting
like cuz to me it made sense you know um
you know my mom had testified in court
against him and um you know she ended up
taking everything back that's that's my
mother she took everything back and she
um you know they dropped it you know I
talked to the DA and he was like you
know I there's nothing I can do now and
I was like I'm I'm sorry that's your
that's who you're dealing with that's
all I can give you you know so couple
more hours went by and I'm going to say
this was around like 9 maybe 10: at
night and all my family was kind of
doing all the research you know I was
still at home you know drinking I didn't
I don't really have a heart when I drink
I kind kind of just let it go and um I
got a phone call from my
uncle keep in mind I don't just sit here
and say it's my mom that's you know
dysfunctional and narcissistic you know
manipulative you know I have I come from
a whole family that has different kinds
of problems you know so I get a phone
call from my uncle I put on speaker
phone you know and I was like um I just
heard like sobbing you know and I was
like what's the matter and he was like I
I got got to call you back and I was
like you got to call me back and I was
like you you got to tell me what's going
on right now cuz now you got now I'm now
I'm turning like what's going on you
know and I I go outside and he goes um
they they found her they found her body
and I like I I think I
um I think I went into like a I needed
to hear it again I was like who who
found her who did you talk to who you
got to tell me who you talk to before
you just you know drop that on me cuz
remember I I got to call my little
brother I got to call my sister I'm
sorry I and he goes they found her um
they found her body you know by the
train tracks it's her and I immediately
um I've always dreaded that day you know
cuz when you're dealing with someone
that very selfish very narcissistic and
that mentally sick you know they don't
they don't think about you you know it's
all about them you know and she's you're
not going to give me money then I'm
going to go kill myself if you're not
going to do this I'm going to go kill
myself you know and her men don't want
to talk to her she's not thinking about
us she's just saying how she's going to
kill herself so I immediately broke down
I I can't even describe to you the
feeling you know I dropped my knees and
um um my boyfriend just you know he held
me you know I didn't even want to be
held I just I screamed I cried to a
point where
I I think I lost all like control of my
body I couldn't even
move and I sat there thinking to myself
for like the first hour like did she did
she die like ugly did you did you suffer
did
he did you die alone you know did you
sit there and lay there and you know
like I I broke down and I had to make
that phone call to my sister and to get
on the phone and hear my sister
screaming the way that she did and I
wasn't strong enough to make the phone
call to my little brother I know I had I
had to let my sister be the big sister
and she placed the phone call to my
brother I didn't want to hear it and we
spent the
then um we ended up coming together at
my house
and gosh we sat there and we cried for
the longest time I was you know
screaming
and and then come the morning time after
I had drank myself into this you know
three four wine bottles later we get a
phone call in the
morning and
um my little brother said that um that
she was alive
and I didn't know whether or not to
believe like okay like see it's up and
down all over again I was like okay well
I don't I don't think that's true
because I was just told that a medical
examiner you know found her or has her
body or whatever the case may be you
know
so uh a couple of days went by I was
with my um with my sister and I had I
drank myself to a point where I I was
like you know what I got to I got to go
home I don't feel right my body doesn't
feel right I feel like something
something's wrong something's going on
so I go home and um I ended up having to
go to the hospital I excuse my language
I really I up my kidneys really
really bad you know and
um I went home and
then I got a phone call from the same
uncle and he told me
um oh she it wasn't her
it was somebody else with the same you
know reaper tattoo except for this lady
had green
eyes in my head I couldn't I couldn't
like I couldn't process it I couldn't
process that I already have to deal with
this person but you should know to just
you know you got to be sure about these
things be sure make sure that you're and
thinking in my head like professionally
a medical examiner is going to I don't
even I can't think of a medical examiner
calling someone you know and just like
oh okay like I was expecting like police
at the door or something but it was like
I think it hurt me to a point where it's
like I'm I'm surrounded by this this is
my family this is what I'm going to deal
with this is my you know this is my kids
family you know and I was
very disappointed with my
uncle and very disappointed with my mom
you know and
um I just couldn't I couldn't like I
couldn't process it you know till this
day you know I haven't said anything I
have not told that story and opened up
that she's even alive I'm actually
opening up here you know so when they
see it it's like
it's and the thing that hurt me the most
is when I finally messaged her phone I
was like are you what's going on like
are you are you listening are you can
you answer me can you text me
something and she ends up messaging my
uncle this long this long story like you
know I don't need to prove myself to
anyone I was here I was not doing
anything wrong and how sad that the
homeless checked up on me instead of my
own family and this and like I could not
believe it I could not believe it I was
just like do you know what I just went
through what your son just went through
what your grandkids just went through
what my sister just went through you
know like I I could not believe it I
could not process it I
couldn't I couldn't believe that I
allowed her to get inside my head like
that all over again again you know and
that's
what that's what I think the worst part
of dealing with someone that's like that
is because a suicidal person isn't going
to speak on it I believe personally this
is just my opinion because um believe me
I'll tell you you know someone that did
in my family and didn't speak on it or
anything you know but to deal with
someone like
her and I love her and I want the best
for her and I want to help her but yet
you can you could care less what like to
tell me like you know the homeless care
more than I did I was just so
heartbroken with her I was heartbroken I
was sick bad I had really did a number
on myself that day you know and then
days later having to go to the hospital
the hospital told me like if you would
have drank and kept going you know you
probably wouldn't even be here you know
and the only reason why I didn't keep
drinking was because my sister my sister
was like I'm going to we're going to go
back up to my house I'm going to take
you with me I was like No just leave me
here just leave me here take take my
daughter you know just leave me
here but there's no fighting with my
sister so I just you know I got in the
car but a couple days later I I started
I started my sobriety cuz I thought to
myself like if I'm going to completely
cut off you know this toxic person I'm
not going to cut out toxic to be toxic
to raise my kids the way that she was
raising us you know so it was real this
is the and my
opinion this is my my personal testimony
you know and this is the only time I can
say that that woman has honestly helped
me your dysfunctional ways
have honestly they I know it sounds
crazy but it's like it it saved me
because now I'm am 39 days sober today
and that's the longest I have been since
2019 when I got sober for a year good
for you thank you so this is just does
this kind of thing happen with your mom
before oh yeah just not not to this
extent you know but I've we've gotten
phone calls that you know she she writes
it on her own Facebook you know rip and
then she'll put her picture right there
do you know anything about her
background how she was raised um I've
heard stories I've heard stories um
I I've never um I can't believe a lot of
what my mom says she is a she's a
real man I don't know whether to you
know reward her for being that good or
do I just keep my distance you know but
she's just really really good at she can
man she can tell you a story you know
and I felt like she
um I don't think she was raised the best
you know I do I'm aware of my my
grandmother my grandmother is a very
very hard worker but a very depressed
woman very depressed woman so hearing
the stories from my aunt my uncle you
know I can't I can't really speak on it
because I don't know know my grandmother
wasn't necessarily you know the nicest
woman to me but um she was very loving
with my sister you know um I'll let my
sister more or less you know I don't I
like I said I don't like to speak on
things that I don't know 100% about just
what I've seen you know my grandfather
was um correctional officer he was you
know amazing but he had his he was
stressed out you know he was stressed
out my grandma drank you know drinking
runs in my family I feel like we got
alcohol running through our body more
than anything thing
but yeah she was a very depressed woman
she would drink all the time so when my
grandfather would come home late nights
everyone's drinking my uncles were
constantly fighting like awful like
we've seen fights where they would if
they weren't beating the life out of
each other they were one time my uncle
stabbed my other Uncle you know and it
was and we were there we were seeing all
this so if it wasn't chaos in one house
it was chaos in the other it was just no
matter where we went it followed
everywhere but at the same time I would
rather be at my grandparents house than
you know be with my mom you know she's
she's good she's really good
she's the only time I've ever talked in
um told my school what had happened her
the man that was molesting me put a put
a big bruise on my leg and she sent me
to school in shorts and they asked me
and you know how they give you that you
know this is nobody's going to hear
anything it's just me and you they give
you that that Rundown make you trust
them you know and I I I told her you
know I was like you know he's he did it
and she used to make me walk home this
was in we were in
Fontana um I went home by the time I got
there uh there was a social worker there
already and whatever that story my mom
was able to say she was able to get that
social work out of there and my mom beat
the out of me that day I couldn't
even go to school the next day that's
how bad it
was and she
just yeah my mom was she didn't she
didn't take care of us like she should
have you know I met your your family
your is it your husband uh no boyfriend
boyfriend and two kids yeah two kids
beautiful yes thank you beautiful yeah
they have two different two different
dads so they're they're those are my
saviors those are you seem to be doing a
great job with your life now now I'm
going to say now I I would never you
know put out to the world like on my
social media I've I've barely started to
open up and tell you know tell what's
going on from from the time I was
actually able to like make my own
decisions I have always said and you can
ask anybody that knows me I have always
always wanted to write a book I am a
writer I love to write my journals
that's what I dove into is my journals
and
music um I always told my family like
I'm going to get older and I'm going to
write a book you know like it's always
been my thing cuz that's my only safety
and trust that I had was in that book
you know my mom broke it so many times
she would she would make fun of me she
would you know she would read them and
then I'd get beat for what I'm writing
you know so it was very it was it's it
was a process you know but now um I've
been through my own you know my own
with my kids I feel like my my daughter
was my daughter's been with me that my
my day one you know and I felt like her
loyalty is just as strong is my loyalty
when I was little you know so um I had
them taken away by CPS you did uh yeah
20 2022 because of you were drinking uh
yeah I played a big role yeah it played
a big role
um we
uh we would get my boyfriend's kids um
only every other
weekend and um at that time you know I
don't I don't like being Li to you know
I rather just if you're hey if you're
falling down the hill then just tell me
you know especially with dope um I
don't I mean I'm glad and thankful that
I didn't fall into dope you know I have
a very addictive personality you know I
smoke a vape and I'm like that's going
to be it drinking is my poison you know
but dope is just I think I've grown a
hate to it because my mom you know and
then my sister at one point you know but
my sister recovered you know wonderfully
she's a great mother you know and
me I I didn't think I would ever end up
with someone that that you know got
addicted to that you know
and and
um I knew he was doing
it and I think it pissed me off because
he kept lying about it when you know
someone you know someone you know and I
knew he was doing it I just I was
getting pissed off cuz I didn't want to
be Li to you know we had had you know
our relationship has been Rocky since
the very beginning you know but when I
feel like when broken Meats broken you
guys feel like you guys can fix each
other you know put all those pieces back
together as one you know like you always
feel like you got to save someone else
and we um started off Rocky we you
know I can honestly say at least today I
can be like we're we're all right we're
all right right now you know but at that
time we weren't all right I knew he was
doing it and I had like the fuckets I
was like I'm going to I'm going to drink
then I'm going to drink and I'm going to
pick on you like that's how that was my
you know that was my thinking that was
my bad you know and um we had fought
physically you know multiple times
before but particularly that night uh I
drank on it I stewed on it when I could
have just left it alone he had his kids
unfortunately that weekend and I had my
daughter that weekend and um my son was
uh 2 and a half months at that time and
I was just you know I was angry and when
I drink I like like any other person you
know I'm going to I'm going to get angry
and that's exactly what I did did you
know so when I came inside I started
like just I know you're lying and this
and that you know I was saying out loud
like I know you're on dope and this and
that you know I was just I was going for
the
jugular we ended up um we ended up
fighting and um the kids were there you
know they they seen and stuff
and um he doesn't have
the the best other mother of the kids
you know particularly I would say she's
a very very vindictive person has been
from the beginning she don't get what
she wants and she knows where to hit him
where it hurts you know and he's a good
dad and he loves his kids you know he's
been fighting for his kids till this day
he's fighting for his kids and um she's
just not I don't think she's I don't
think she's a good person that's how I'm
going to lay it out there you know I try
not to have so much you know hostility
towards people but I just say it how it
is you know and the phone call was not
placed out of concern it was U I want to
say it was an opportunity because she
wants him completely out of you know
their lives and I think she took that
opportunity and I don't sit here and say
like you know it's her fault it's this I
learned in therapy like my therapist
gave me a good you know she didn't have
your kids taken away you had your kids
taken away and that's exactly how I look
at it because I did you know and um the
phone call was placed uh a couple days
after the fight you know 24 hours CPS is
going to be at the door well
unfortunately when they did come to the
house it was like 11:00 at night I was
heavily intoxicated neither one of my
kidss were there my daughter was
actually across the way at a um at a
friend's house and I was with one of my
friends and we were just drinking you
know and they came there and I became
very very you know defensive I was
telling them that I was absolutely not
drinking when you could smell it on my
breath you know they had officers with
them you know I was very I was very you
know
defensive so um of course they use that
against me which I can't I don't sit
here and you know deny it but
um so after that they started doing the
okay well we're going to give you the
resources I didn't want the resources I
was just like nope I don't want anything
to do with you like and I already have
it out for CPS because I've you know I
should have been taken from my mom I
don't know how you didn't see that I
don't how you know all the medical stuff
that I've been through I don't know how
I wasn't taken none of us were taken you
know so personally I feel like that the
system you know you you did you failed
me you failed me you fa my brother my
sister you know but that's another story
so um
so she um she started making home visits
you know um at that point I'm going to
say like maybe 10 days went by I
completely cut off all communication
with CPS I didn't um which is the worst
thing I could have done I cut off all
communication I didn't answer the door I
didn't answer uh the police nothing so I
got to the point where February 3rd they
came and U my daughter got off the bus
she came in and not 20 minutes later
they were knocking at the door again and
I thought it was just you know same
thing I'm they're just not going to
answer the door they're going to leave
well then like another 30 minutes went
by and they came and they came with the
sheriff's and they said they have a
warrant and they're going to bust down
the door you know in my head I'm
thinking like just we should just open
the door but you know I we didn't and
they they broke down the door and they
walked directly up and Mark has a um
your boyfriend yeah he has a um
he has a criminal history so he
immediately got
um he got taken out pretty pretty bad
you know so I was the only one there
with my um sorry this is very this is
where I get like
um she walked up to me and she told me
that um we're here to place your
children in protective custody and in my
head I got very defensive I got like
you're not taking my kids anywhere you
know and I started getting to the point
where it was like you know my daughter
was like holding on to me and you know
my son I had my son you know I was
nursing at that time and I was
real I was getting defensive and I was
starting to get to the point where you
know what if you're going to if you
think you're going to take my kids you
might as well just shoot me you know
like I'm I'm not going to give you my
kids but seeing how my daughter was
reacting my daughter was she was like
starting to hyperventilate she was
starting to you know my daughter's very
very intelligent unusually intelligent
and I knew she knew it and so I just had
like a tunnel vision
moment where I thought to myself like it
doesn't matter how hard I fight right
now it doesn't matter what I say what I
do they're going to take them anyway you
know and the best thing I can do right
now as a mother is just calm her down
you know so I asked for 5 minutes I I
got her um I got her in the room and I
was able to tell her like I I'll get you
out if I don't come for you believe me
somebody you know will will come for you
you know at that time her dad was
incarcerated so I couldn't you know
really go to him but um I ended up
reaching out to his family and they
ended up taking both of my kids so um
they were out of placement they stayed
in placement for 24 hours and then
another 24 hours in temporary foster
until they went with relatives they were
there for a month until I was able to
get them back um you know having to do
my classes and stay sober and me myself
I'm a very you know intelligent person
you know right now I'm in school for
criminal justice and the only that
motivated me with that was because you
know CPS and how my kids were being
treated I felt like they were being
treated more like a number than they
were you know actually what's what's
best for them you know they were telling
me that they're going to come make home
visits and they they never came you know
like I would see them like at you know
the end of the month and stuff so I have
my my fair share you know a lot of my
drinking took a lot of the first couple
of years away with my daughter you know
I was
dancing um I was drinking you know when
I was living with my family at that time
well they were living with me and then
um I just kind of leave the
responsibility to my sister like oh she
needs to eat dinner this that you know
like my sister was like the wife at home
in a way I just you know went to the
clubs and I think um the dancing was a
way for me to forget about everything
some days I would just sit and just
drink I wouldn't even work it was just a
place for me to just sit there and be
left alone so I can just sit there and
drink I'd start fights I would you know
wasn't never been the best Drinker never
will be the best Drinker you know
effects of dealing with your mom is
inspiration for getting straight now
yeah yeah cuz she's you know there's a
time where you got to just you got to
turn your back you know and I I don't
know how I would react if I got the real
news like the final news you know cuz
now I feel like
you've she's put me in a position where
it's like I'm I think that's where God
comes in cuz this is honestly the
closest I've been with I'm not like a
you know Holy Roller or anything I just
this is the first time in my life that
I've welcomed prayer and reached out
because I got to a point where I was
like I can't I can't live like this you
know like i' all I've ever wanted from
that woman was just her love her
attention you know some trust here and
there you know and hearing the stories
even when I was younger cuz I I was
actually not even supposed to be here I
was supposed to die from the tumor that
I got when I was six so um I don't
remember uh very much I remember the
hospital I was in L
Melinda I remember um just always being
in pain my sister always told me you
know like
you you've always you were always in
pain you know you'd want to come and
play or you'd want to eat something you
were just always in pain you know and uh
one time my grandparents came to visit
um I had like the biggest stomach you
know everybody told me like you looked
pregnant you know and by the time they
got me there
the hospital said it was it was too late
you know like you this is a tumor how
did you let it you know and how do you I
think about it now too like how do you
how do you not see that how do you not
see a tiny I was a very tiny girl you
know how did you not see your own
daughter you know in pain how did you
not pay attention you know and that was
not my first trip to the hospital
um my mom one time
um
she she dropped like her like a like a
ball of meth inside of her beer one time
and from the beginning that I can
remember my mom's always giv us beer you
know that pink tequila that they the
Tequila Rose we would have little sips
of that here and there you know to put
us to sleep she was man I've been taking
Nyquil for since since I was young she
used to call it our cocktails you know
so um she was drinking you know in her
she used to say you know once my nose
gave out I had to do something else so
she would put it in her beer she put in
her beer one time and I drank that I I
took a I took a big drink out of her
beer and you know my uncle told me like
he's like when I was holding you and he
was like I can like see your heart you
know and there again you know where was
CPS how do you go to a hospital how do
you explain you
know a child you know that's coming in
here positive for meth and you're just I
don't understand it you know I've never
understood it you know and that
and you not seeing the fact that I was
being you know molested at any
opportunity in front of her in plain
sight you know not not like in front of
her but in plain sight you know he would
get me when I was she'd be cooking and
I'd have to just sit there with this you
know sick not stomach and it was like I
didn't I didn't understand why you know
at that time I that's why my
grandparents usually were my safe Zone
and as crazy as that sounds cuz over
there it's wasn't no better it was
dysfunctional over there too you know
but at least I know I'm not you know
being touched over there you know and I
felt like I made the grave mistake one
time of I told my Uncle you know um I
was really close with my uncle and I
told my Uncle I felt like that to me
that was the worst mistake I could have
made cuz my uncle like blew up he waited
for him to come home you know they ended
up fighting physically and my mom again
she was like look what you did look what
you did you know you open your big mouth
and it's like I started realizing maybe
like eight or nine she knew she knew and
that that wasn't just the you know the
first person you know um she would take
me
to these people's houses and Fontana she
would I don't know they were like this
weird swinger
couple and they had kids and I got
molested by one of their kids you know
and I never said anything I was just
like it started to become normal it
started to just become like you know
what it's this is my life this is you
know like that's why family pictures are
very hard you know cuz looking at them
there's always something behind them
there's always a story behind them or
that happened on that day you know so
it's
very we me and my sister don't we don't
like looking at the pictures you know
so I feel like surviving this is
is I think I'm a hell of a lot more sane
than I should be you know cuz
I I think I've put myself through so
much and blamed her for so
much you know that I just I
self-destructed that's how I was always
F you know my uncles used to tell us oh
you guys are going to be pregnant when
you're like 16 and it's like yeah well
whatever you know my mom was a dancer
that's what made me you know say it
I'll dance too cuz you know and I didn't
tell her I didn't want to tell her I was
ashamed to tell her you know but I ended
up having to spit it out and honestly I
I was like what are you mad for you did
it you know at one point she was like
my I wanted to be like her I was like
man my mom's really tough she goes out
there she fights all these women she
takes on these men you know like not
realizing
how how
dysfunctional that's the only word I can
use for it how bad this is you know and
I always it was normal to me you know
until this day you know I still have
contact with the man that you know
molested me I
still you know I I went down almost the
same exact path you know I dove in a
drink I've been drinking with my mom for
a long time Friday was the day every
Friday it's like all right we're going
to we're going to drink you know like
she would give me she would give me
alcohol before I would take my test when
I was going to school you know she give
me water bottles of Cisco and I was like
all right well you know and they're over
there telling me like what is that smell
you know like and I just you know I
managed to keep going to school that's
one thing that
um my little brother managed to graduate
without no motivation you know and she
was a
very difficult person you know and the
only person I feel like
I I looked up to as a male you know male
Idol was my my my
grandfather my grandfather was you know
he was to me was everything in that
family you know he was like the glue you
know he's a very grouchy man but when
you get older you start realizing like
he was grouchy cuz he had to pay all
these bills you know he had to file for
bankruptcy you know
and she's always been like an an
entitled person you know she treated my
grandfather like that cuz I guess that's
how she grew up you know he always
spoiled her that's where I feel like she
got this you know she's so entitled like
you guys have to take care of me what am
I supposed to do I don't have any money
on the streets and it's
like I don't get a job or maybe you know
but she always crutches on that I'm
mental I can't you know like I'm not
allowed to work I'm not
liked you know and my grandfather was
my he was he was great man you know
really good man provided for his family
and at the end um my grandfather started
getting um not Alzheimer's uh what is
that other one dementia yeah he started
getting dementia you know my grandfather
always told us you know if I start
getting like that just take me out to
the backyard and shoot me I always be
like go don't don't talk like that you
know but he
um that's exactly what what he did um
2016 he just I think he had enough my
mom drained him like a lot financially
emotionally you know she started little
by little taking things away from him I
mean he wasn't able to drive but you
know um
you know she would be taking money from
the safe and you know slowly but surely
that can really break someone down you
know when you have everything you go
from providing having your house nice
and this to just being completely
everything just taken out you know right
beneath you and
2016 um we were all outside and we try
to keep the smoking away from him you
know it was it's like a game we
hear him coming or the back door slam
you know everybody better run you know
and it wasn't that we were going to get
in trouble it was because it was don't
don't do that in front of you know don't
I call him Dad we call him dad and
um he came outside and my little brother
goes oh look there's there's Dad he's
like he just waved at me and I was like
oh okay you
know um my brother noticed he was
dressed and I noticed his whole room was
clean he put his little dog in the back
and um he got really dressed you know
his turquoise necklace like he's you
know and not even like 3 4 minutes later
uh I remember I was smoking a great
presidential and I went past it and you
just heard a loud bang and we all kind
of stopped cuz it sounded similar to a
firework but you know the difference if
you know you know the difference between
you know a gunshot and a firework my
little brother goes dad's outside he
went to the back so we all got up you
know my mom booked it first you know and
gosh I she let out out this she got like
right cuz the garage is in the back she
just got like right there to where she
can see all the way in the back she just
let out this horrible scream you know
she's like no and just screamed you know
and I was I went to grab
her and
um she she told me he he shot himself
and I went to look over and at that time
I had a friend that went back there he
was there and he he yelled to me and he
was like um your dad's still
alive so I went running back there you
know I
um I went and I looked at him and he had
um he used a python and he shot himself
like I don't I think he maybe meant to
do it a different way but he just kind
of got himself in the throat so in the
front I looked at it and I was just like
you know automatically how I you know
how he always taught me I kind of went
medical I was like okay well this looks
not that bad and but I can you know hear
the gurgle and stuff
and I uh I went to pull him forward cuz
I wanted to see I didn't want to touch
him you know or or you know but I had um
pulled him
forward and I seen the back of his neck
and the back of the neck was just you
know completely blown
out so I pushed him back forward and I
just I called and I was like just you
know and I sat there with him
and I think
um everything I told him cuz I just
couldn't help but just tell him like
this is probably the last I'm not he's
not going to make it you know he's an
older man I just told him um you know I
love you you know and I'm I don't know
why you did this but I I love you and in
my head I
think he felt like he didn't serve a
purpose
anymore you know cuz he was the kind of
man that people
would come over and he would just want
to talk to
you
and everybody kind of would just like oh
okay yeah you know walk away even me you
know
sometimes and I felt like maybe he felt
like he didn't serve any kind of purpose
to us anymore
so I just told him you know I love you
I've always loved you thank you for
everything that you've done and I'm
sorry I'm sorry this you know this
happened to you I'm sorry I promised
myself I wasn't going to cry you know
and
um after that I
uh
after thank
you after um they got him into a um a
helicopter you know and he ended up
making it to the hospital he lived for a
couple of days but he had signed um this
thing that he didn't want to be uh
artificially prolonged he didn't want to
you know so we were going head-to-head
with
the with the hospital and stuff and they
told us you know he's not going to he's
not going to have a good life you know
so my mom ended up letting him go
you know and not even a couple
of weeks later you know everything
started getting sold off you know like
it's
it's I think a mother has the power
to to give a child the best love to
always remember that and when they go
you're not going to be sad you'll be sad
but you're just going to have those such
good memories of that woman that it's
going to motivate you to keep going and
to keep you know make her proud even if
she's not here and a mother has the
power an evil power to make her children
feel just
worthless and I feel like
that's that's what my mom did you know
she betrayed my trust and she made me
feel like I like I was nothing to her
when she was my
everything you know and I can never sit
here and blame
her for what I do as as an
adult you know but when I had my
daughter I just wasn't you know I wasn't
ready to settle down you know
and and I wasted so much time you know
and now I felt like I always feel like I
you know I did worse than my mom I got
my kids taken away you know but
everything happens you know for for a
reason I feel like this is exactly what
was supposed to happen to me you know
and I can't help but to sit here and
think like you know
what
she she helped me to just turn this
around you know will I ever speak to her
again probably
not probably not I have to find
forgiveness with her but you know going
through all of this and watching her you
know almost kill herself for men like
and many times many times you know my
mom would
be she threw herself out of a car one
time a moving car we were on the freeway
you know and I had to watch watch her I
had to watch her roll and then hit the
wall and then I look back and I'm like
gosh woman like when is this going to
stop you know why are you
so why are you so weak you know what is
your biggest fear right now my biggest
fear is falling back in
alcohol and
becoming becoming what she is not
finding that strength not finding the
strength to leave a toxic
relationship not finding the strength to
know the difference between
you know my reality or is it am I doing
this for me you know do I stay in this
you know I'll never forgive myself for
for the CPS thing
because as their mother as their
nurturer I should have been the one to
to walk away I should have walked away
for the sake of my kids and for the sake
of you know my own you know my own
personal reasons I should have left when
I seen the red flags I should have left
when the toxic was you know right in
front of me but I wasn't strong enough
and because of that my kids had to pay
the price for it you know and that's
hard you know like domestic violence
when you hear domestic violence you kind
of some people think like oh it's one
person or it's you know I'm getting beat
you know cuz at that time they didn't
they didn't even give me a chance to
explain it's like I don't consider
myself like a battered woman we when we
fight like you know and there goes my
mother's kind of mentality like I'm not
going to call the cops on you you know
I'm gonna lock that door we're g to see
who comes out the bigger man you know
but it's like what
what kind of how is that normal you know
how do you survive that how do you you
know get through that and I have two
different kinds of people watching me I
have my son watching me and my daughter
is she going to well my mom went through
it I can go through it you know like I
wasn't proud that wasn't going through
my head I'm sitting here thinking like
oh I know you're doing drugs and I'm
going to find out one way or another you
know and no you could just leave the
whole situation that is what a mother is
supposed to do that's that's where you
know that's my biggest fear is is not
being able to find that strength to be
like you know
what I got to I got to just you know
walk away from this you know so I think
our sobriety has been you know it's been
good mine um mine was more recent you
know cuz
I I'm terrible when I drink and
everybody knows it people in the strip
club will tell you you know like because
I've hold I've held in so much of this
bage you know when you drink you start
to become you know the old man at the
bar telling his Vietnam stories nobody
wants to hear that nobody wants to
hear it like all right you know like you
know and that's how it would that's how
it would come we'd be having I'd go from
having you know a couple of shots we're
feeling good making some money to
just like this is what I went through
you know like you guys don't understand
like just pouring it all out this is why
I feel like since as long as I have
known you know this is my my book is
like you know my family tells me like
what are you waiting for it's like man I
got I got so much in here I don't know
how I'll feel like when I start writing
like I'm tearing through the paper
because it's like you just want to let
it all out I feel like closure is
something that I've never had in my life
not with relationships not with my mom
like how can a person go through so much
and that's it you just got to you just
got to deal with it you know it makes me
sad you know nobody should have to go
through that and some people are
embarrassed to let out their stories I
was I was I was I didn't want to tell
anybody what I went through I don't want
to be that person that you know I wanted
to I wanted to in my head I wanted to
just let it go you know and just move
forward but it's like it doesn't work
that way not for me Jessica what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in all of
this most important lesson
is not letting your past your
history and who you were Define
you honestly cuz that's what I think I
did I let everything just and I'm not
I'm not a bad person we can all reinvent
ourselves at any time oh yeah oh yeah
definitely definitely that's why it's
that's not just for you know me I see
all I see all kinds of you know your
stories you know I I see it and if
anything you know it's it's
everybody's going through something you
might not believe it you can you can
have the nicest clothes you can have
nicest shoes you can have the nicest car
but nobody knows what's going on you
know what nobody's going
on inside your head you know and that's
where I feel like i' I've L it for so
long I'm 31 years old I catch myself
like it's too late for me you know
therapy I can go to therapy I
particularly had to do it when I was in
CPS I loved therapy but I have so much
built up that I'd get get pissed off cuz
an hour wasn't enough like well there
goes $150 I didn't even get it all out
you know like you start to think like
what am I supposed to do
now now some people don't get that
privilege like it's either $150 on my
therapy and I work on myself or am I
going to spend $150 on these groceries
and these kids you know I don't get I
don't get some people don't get both of
those you know luxuries at the same
time and me I still have to keep telling
myself like I'm still okay I'm 31 but I
still have a I still got some time you
know cuz sometimes just like no I don't
need therapy I'm
already my life's already technically
over I've lived a long life but what I
tell myself today that keeps me going
and why I'm going to you'll hear you'll
hear more of me you'll see me more cuz I
I'm going to stick by this is I lived
very shitty life I lived a very shitty
dysfunctional life you know that's not
even half of what you know everything
I've been through but I won't die like
this I'm not going to be that story that
sad story that my kids are going to go
tell their kids that's not how I'm going
to go
out so excellent Jessica wish you the
best thank you thank you very
much
that